foreign
python is one of the emerging
programming languages according to the
most recent figures python is the most
used coding language for about 80
percent of developers in the syntax of
this high-level programming language is
simple to understand and Python's large
Library System makes it a best choice
for data science machine learning and
artificial intelligence projects
so hello Learners welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel and today we will
be writing code to solve Sudoku using
python
but before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel
like the tutorial and hit the Bell icon
to now miss an update
and before starting let us have a simple
quiz question to brush upon our
knowledge
and your question is which one of the
following has the highest precedence in
the expression and your options are
division subtraction power or
parenthesis
please answer in the comment section
below and we'll update the correct
answer in the pin comment you can pause
the video give it a thought and answer
in the comment section
and I have an insightful for you guys
that is if you are focused on building
strong foundational skills for career
growth in that case you can check out a
free course to Learn Python Basics with
a completion certification from scale up
by simply learn you can check the scores
with the link in the description box
below
and from here we'll start the tutorial
first I will show you
Sudoku we will be solving the Sudoku
that would be the 9 cross 9
metrics
so the objective of Sudoku game is to
fill a 9 cross 9 grid with digits so
that each column each row and each of
the line that is three cross three
subgrids that is the Three cross three
sub boxes that compose the grid they
should contain all the digits from 1 to
9. and the puzzle Setter provides a
partially completed grid which for a
well post puzzle has a single solution
so you can see on your screen
this is the Sudoku puzzle that we're
gonna solve
so I will
tell you
what are the rules to solve a Sudoku
so this is a 9 cross 9 grid that is 9
rows and nine columns 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
and 9 columns that is one two three four
five six seven eight nine
so what are the rules if we pick a
number that is 9.
we have to fill one to nine digits that
is in the row in the column and in this
grid
you can see this grid
so in this box so we pick a number nine
so this should be single present in the
row
in the column and in this grid
you can't repeat this number in row in
column or in this grid you have to
complete this grid that is you have to
complete one we have one two three we
have to complete four we have five six
and we have to complete seven and eight
if we see we can't fill it here as we
have the number eight in this row
so it won't come here it would come here
so you can see that we have filled 8
here similarly we will fill four and
seven to complete one to nine digits in
this box and similarly we should have
one two nine digits in a row and in a
column and there should be no repetition
and to solve this we would be using the
recursive algorithm
so telling about recursive algorithm
it's a problem solving technique in
which problems are solved by reducing
them to smaller problems of the same
form
in programming recursion simply means
that a function will iteratively cool
itself
so
to play the game you could visit a
website that is sudoku.com and you can
set your difficulty level that could be
easy medium hard expert and Evil so they
would just change the numbers and reduce
the numbers and they will increase their
difficulty level
as you choose it
you could easily play the game here
and if you write a wrong like
2 is present in this small subgrade that
is three cross three and I have entered
the number two so it's showing me in the
red
color
it states that this number won't be
placed here it's a wrong number
so backspace it
you can see how to play a Sudoku game
I think you are clear with the rules now
moving on
we'll start with the project to solve a
Sudoku with recursive algorithm so we'll
write a code in Python to solve the
Sudoku puzzle we just have to enter the
Grid in the code only and you can see
how it will solve
so the first thing would be
we will create a folder for our project
and we'll create
in Python projects
we will create a new folder
and name it as Sudoku solver
and inside we will call the command
prompt
and
we will run a command that is called
space period to open our Visual Studio
code you can choose any ideally that you
have hand shown
I would be using the visual studio code
you could use anyone
so here comes our widget Studio code and
here we'll create a file and name it as
Sudoku Dot py
and here we will start our code to solve
our Sudoku and we would be using the
recursive algorithm here
so first we will import numpy Library
to
get a Sudoku in a grid
and numpy helps us with that
so for that we'll import numpy
and we'll use Lis that would be SNP
so we could just use NP
for using the numpy library functions or
classes
so here we will create a grid for Sudoku
puzzle
for that we will write a variable name
Sudoku puzzle and inside we will pass
the Sudoku puzzle
that is we will write
all the numbers
we want to get sold
so we'll be using this Sudoku puzzle
only
this is the easy level Sudoku and we
would be writing the code for the same
and our code will work for all the
Sudoku that would be the easy medium
hard any level
So currently we'll use this Sudoku and
these rows and column and these numbers
with the same pattern and
we would represent the blank boxes with
zero so we will create a grid variable
in Python and the blank cells they would
be represented with 0.
so we will start
filling our Sudoku here that would be
9 comma 6 comma 2
and for blank spaces we would write 0
8
comma 5
comma 0 comma zero
now here
I have all the
all the numbers in the Sudoku I have
copied them
and now I will directly paste it for you
guys
so we don't waste time just writing or
creating the Sudoku puzzles we will move
further and see how we can solve this
Sudoku with the help of recursive
backtracking
and to solve this first we'll create a
function and name it as possibility and
we'll pass three parameters in that that
would be row column and the number that
we would be entering
so this function will check if a
particular cell can be filled with a
number n
there will be three checkpoints in this
function
that would check in the vertical
Direction in the horizontal Direction
and in the local 3 cross 3 grid as I
have stated you the rules of the Sudoku
so we'll check if this number is present
in the row in the column with the three
closed three grid then it would return
false and if the number is already
existed in any checkpoint
and if it's not present in any
checkpoint it would return true and the
number would be accepted there this mean
it is possible to fill n in that y comma
X cell that is rho comma XL
the grid
so moving on we will create the function
and
to create a function we will write
daf and the name of the function that
would be possibility
and in that we'll pass three arguments
that is row
column
and the number
which we would be entering in the
particular cell
so here
first we will set
this variable in which we have inserted
the Sudoku puzzle will
set it as Global so we could use
globally in the whole code
Sudoku underscore puzzle
and now
we will run a for Loop to check if the
number we are entering is appearing in
the given row if it appears we'll return
false and if it not we will return true
so we will run a loop and for that we'll
write for I
in range
and the range would be from
0 to 9
and if
Sudoku underscore puzzle
that is
here we will enter row
so what we are doing is
if we
see the Sudoku puzzle we will get the
first row
and then
just adjacent to it we will pass the I
that would be ranging from 0 to 9 so it
will check in the whole row that is 0th
1 second third fourth fifth sixth
seventh eighth it would check in the
whole row if the number is present so it
would return false
is equal to equal to number that we
would be entering in the empty cell
so
if the number matches we would return
false
and similarly
we will run a loop for column
for that we'll write
o i
in range
that is range would be from 0 to 9 only
and we will run a conditional statement
that would be if
Sudoku puzzle
and here
first we'll write I and then the column
and if it's
equal to equal to
so we have written column with the
capital c
that is equal to num
that the number we would be entering in
the particular cell
if it's
equal then we'll return false
so we have would be writing the colon
we would return false
and now I will tell you what we have
done here
so
we have written I and the column is
fixed here
so in this column
we will check if the number we gonna
enter
is
already present in the particular column
then it would return false so if we take
any column as
we pass any column in the argument that
is we have passed the second third
fourth column and
there we would run the loop to check all
the columns there that would be
per second third fourth fifth sixth
seventh eighth ninth and if there's the
number present that we are entering it's
both are equal then we'll return false
so we have covered
two rules here for the Sudoku puzzle
that is row and column now we will be
discussing about the grid part that is
the Three cross three grid if the number
is present in the grid then we'll also
return false there
so for that
first we will create a variable
that would be X
and that would be equal to
column
floor division
by 3
and into three
and Y
that is equal to
rho
division
by 3.
into 3.
so what I am trying to insert in this
variable that is we would be passing the
column
in the parameter so that column would be
4 divided by 3 and then it would be
multiplied by 3.
so if I will tell you if we
pass a row that would be
the first row so one floor division by
three so what it will give us it will
give us 0.
because flow division gives us the
nearest
integer
so for two also it would give us 0
and for 3 it would give us 1.
and for 4
it would give us 1 that would be 4
division three
that would be one
and after that we are multiplying by
three so it will give us
t
and similarly you can see for all the
rows and the column
so I will tell you here
but we are gonna do that is in a
variable
that is X inside that
we are just entering the column which we
are passing in the function and we are
doing four division with three and
multiplying it with
3.
so what we are getting
if we just take the column 1
that is
one
low division with three
so what will it give us it would give us
0. and if we take another column that is
the next column that would be the second
column
and if we flow divided by 3 it would
give us 0.
so these are the column what we would be
passing in a function
similarly
third column it would give us one
and for the fourth column
it will also give us 1 and for the fifth
column
it will
give us 1 and now here for the sixth
column
it would give us
2.
and similarly for the others it would
give us 2 and for the ninth column it
would give us three
so if I tell you seven flow division
three
that would be 2
8 row division three
it would give us 2
and 9 for division three
it would give us 3.
so
I will
tell you what we are going to do here
and
after that you would
understand
forward purpose we are just creating
this variable and inside we are passing
column with the flow division three and
multiplying it with 3.
so if you can see this we'll just clear
it out
so if you see here
if we take the rows here
it would
give
one for this 0 for this
and
one for this
and two for this
now we will
run a loop here
double Loop that would be the nested
loops that would be 4 I in range
that would be from 0 to 3.
and another loop that would be the
nested Loop
o j
n range that is
0 to 3
so inside we'll pass a conditional
statement that would be if
Sudoku puzzle
and here these variables would be
counted that would be y
plus 1
and X
plus one
if it's equal equal to number
then we would return
poles
okay now I will tell you what we have
done here
so
we have to check if we are what the
number we are entering if it's present
in this three cross three grid then our
output would be false
so what we have done here we have taken
the X and if we pass column 0 and it
would be 4 divided by 3 and multiply by
3 it would give us 0 and we have run the
loop for this
and we have given the row also zero
so you will got 0 plus 1 and X would be
also 0 that would be plus 1 and if this
cell is equal to the number then we
would return false
so if we take the row 0
and column 0
that we have already
a number here so we want Row 2 and
column 2.
so for that if we just
get at the
so here as we have
two nested loops
what it states that
if we pass rho equal to 0 and column
equal to 0 that is this
so it will run the loop and it will just
iterate y plus 1 and X Plus 1
will check if it's equal to the number
what we are going to pass if it's the
same
in this grid that is 3 cross 3 grid then
it will return Folds
and similarly
when
will pass column as 1 and row as one
then also the flow division will
and give us 0
and
moving on
it will take us to the next
cell
so this is how we're going to check the
Three cross three grid
so
these three are the rules that we have
covered in the function possibility
and now
we will return true
that is
if these conditions
don't fulfill then we get the true and
that is the number we gonna enter in
that cell
and now
we will create another function that
would be solution and inside that
solution we would be calling this
function
so
that we will
create the function and name it as
solution
and inside
we will make the Sudoku puzzle AS Global
variable
and here
we will run the loop
now we will run the loop for row and
column so that will pass all the rows
and column and we could enter the values
and pass those row and column values
into the function
that is possibility
so I will show you how we're gonna do
that
first we'll run a loop four rows
for Row in range
that is 0 to 9.
and now for column that is
four column
in range
that is
0 to 9
now we have
two nested Loops that is for row and
column they would be covering the rows
and the column and now here we will pass
a conditional statement
that is if the particular cell if it's
equal to 0 then only we gonna get the
enter the number
so for that we would write the
conditional statement that is if
Sudoku underscore puzzle
and the particular row column
that would be fetched by
these loops and if it's equal to 0
then we will run another loop
that is
4
that would be the numbers that would be
in the range one two nine
there is one is included in this when we
use the range function one is included
in this and we have entered the second
digit that is 10 so it would count the
numbers till 9.
and here we would get another
conditional statement that is if we will
call our function that we have created
that is possibility
and past arguments that is row column
and num
that is will pass
row column
and number
and
we will write a condition for that
that is we will get the number entered
in the cell
row column
and that is equal to
number
and this number has been entered and now
we'll call
this function that is the solution
function again
so that
the process goes on
and
when we are at the end of the row or
column or just at the end when we don't
have any cells left so what we will do
foreign
that is we would start the backtracking
again
we will get that cell entered as 0 and
we'll start the backtracking again
okay
and here we will return the function
no
now we want our metrics to be printed
and to print that we'll use the numpy
library that would be NP and its metric
class that is the metric function and
inside would pass the variable
in which we have stored our
puzzle that is Sudoku puzzle
it would get printed and if there are
some more solutions like if you
play the easy level of the Sudoku game
there could be more solutions
so for that
we could get the input that is
we'll get the input from the users if
there are some possible solutions
will just
enter
in the terminal and we can get those
solution and if it's
and if there are no solutions that is no
more possible solutions other than the
one single solution
then
it would end the program
so this is our program
for the Sudoku solver
we'll save it and run it
so you could see that
there is some issue in the code so we
will see what is
so
these are
inside this functions it's maybe the
indentation can be wrong
so we'll save this and run it again
and yeah
you can see that our Sudoku has been
sold
and it's asking for more possible
solutions if we press enter
so it has giveness one more solution
we press again enter that's it there are
two solutions for this Sudoku
and it has provided us both the
solutions
so
this is here we have completed our code
that is for the Sudoku solver using
backtracking or the recursion recursion
algorithm
and with that we have come to the end of
this session and I have an insightful
for you guys that is
I have a course for you guys
that is if you are aiming to get
certified in Python Programming and want
to build a python software development
career in that case you can check this
python certification course by simply
learn that will open the doors for the
best career opportunities and to find
these details you can check the
description box below I will give you
the link there and I will also give you
the code link that would be as our get
Library so I will provide you with the
source code files link also in the
description box below and I hope the
session was interesting and informative
if you liked it please let us know in
the comment section below and also do
subscribe to our Channel and stay tuned
for more from Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here